I love what you're wearing thank you for
an absolutely gorgeous and your hair
let's talk about different that's really
cool you know I really didn't want to do
my Monet and I wanted to have a hair off
with you but we weren't for something
different today you know what's
interesting is yeah because you usually
well in the past you've gone for a
pompadour because of the Monet I call it
the conan cuz it's kinda like that's why
I'm suing you
oh really we're series yeah well let's
let's see there's yours which is that is
impressive I used to be able to pull
that off when I was like 22 I could pile
it up so much get some mayonnaise in
there and then yeah that's it I've
always wanted to you know this is true
because I don't like people touching my
hair please you go at it
no really get your fingers in there come
on let's go no I don't want to do oh
yeah it's not a lace-front you should
wash them there's a lot of weird stuff
in there I use a mousse that's mostly
asbestos
you